[Music]
we have a first here this evening how
long have we been in this talk show game
it's been about 19 years something like
that yeah in 19 years this has never
happened but I just realized that
sometime during the top of the show I
split my pants and I didn't I don't mean
just a little split I mean this is a
giant the back of my pants are falling
off right I don't know exactly when it
happened it might have been that guy but
I'm not kidding check this out I mean
this is just gone
[Applause]
I mean I I noticed it late in the
monologue I was like I feel a draft
breezy and then I at the end I did that
to the guy and I felt fabric moving all
over the place everything was moving
around and so I don't know what I I mean
I don't know what to do I think these
are oh now it's opening up more it's
building you're behind the dash for the
most of the show so yeah fine yeah yeah
you could have just made it your little
secret no but aren't you glad I told you
[Applause]
Hey yeah everything's a-okay
well yeah oh look who's out here it's
Bruce Bromwich who does my wardrobe
Bruce what's the story here Bruce what -
what's jumping around that's what I do
that's my thing that's my shtick we got
to get special clothes made for me that
can stand up to the Conan test right no
we should put a suit we should have
suits made and put on like an orangutan
and if they're still there in a year
then we know that they're good suits
right we'll get them fumigated and then
you can wear them not even fumigated